foreign
Ty all right Professor shot
honest who do you call when you are at
your lowest who is that one person
nobody I'm a man
no one cares
not a single soul
nobody no one cause I'm all alone
speaking for the guys when I say this
literally no one
y'all call someone
[Music]
nobody just nobody
no one I'm a man
TK no one the reason I ask whether or
not this is toxic masculinity there's a
there's an assumption that in order to
be a man
and to be manly
I must behave in a way that doesn't show
weakness ever
I wouldn't call it toxic masculinity
when a bunch of men say
I don't share my problems with anyone
because I'm a man
I would call that
a lot of men sincerely expressing how
they feel
and when we slap a label on that like
toxic masculinity that creates some kind
of War some kind of battle to fight some
kind of resistance
and why the hell would you want to go to
war without being curious about what's
going on first
if anyone tells me I don't have anyone
that I share my problems with
because I am a man that I want to have a
conversation about that
forget about the labels what do you mean
why do you feel that way because whether
you're a man or a woman you need some
kind of accountability some kind of
affirmation some kind of encouragement
and clearly there are a lot of people
out there who feel like the world
doesn't care about how I feel the world
will pick that up as a weakness and I
don't think that's a way to live that
doesn't mean you should be
indiscriminate about just showering your
emotions to anyone who will listen
because there is a great danger in being
vulnerable with people that don't have
your best interest in mind there is
great danger in giving up information
about yourself about struggles about
weaknesses with people that might have
bad intentions or people who aren't
trustworthy or people who haven't proven
themselves but everybody needs a band of
brothers everybody needs a family
everybody needs somebody that they can
walk through life with and share their
heart with so no I wouldn't slap a label
on it I would try to understand it Ryan
I know that you're part of a men's group
and you have talked a lot about this
with me individually like on a personal
level and you talk to your men's group
as well the reason I I talk about toxic
masculinity here I'm not putting that
label on any of these men I want to be
clear I think it's a societal problem
problem when these men feel like they're
not allowed to show emotion to express
they're not even able to call anyone oh
y'all call someone
not even realizing that that is an
option that is the toxic part it's the
societal constraint and expectation that
then permeates the culture and that
culture says Hey in order for you to be
a man you better just suck it up yeah
you know it's crazy the men's team that
I'm on
the foundation is men supporting men
and it
literally is what the entire division
revolves around because of exactly the
video we saw where like men
don't feel like they can ask for support
and
um yeah I also would not label that
video or those men or that trait as
being toxic to me toxic masculinity is
like you know if I were to write a list
of traits
um there are you know certain masculine
traits that you could write down
and when those traits are used to
dominate control manipulate
like I think that is where the toxic
masculinity comes in and that's why I
look at this as toxic masculinity
because these men aren't being toxically
masculine but they are being dominated
or controlled by a societal expectation
that says you can't reach out to anyone
so it's not me saying these men are
doing anything wrong it is society
imposing a particular standard and that
standard in and of itself eyes view as
Toxic by the way some of it is some of
it is real right like I think uh
expressing your problems is a highly
contextual thing where
um just because you have a problem and
you need to express it doesn't mean you
express it at any time with anyone under
any conditions whatsoever and there are
many spaces where it is a reality for
men particularly in competitive spaces
with other men where if you complain
about something or if you express
vulnerability you will get eaten alive
that doesn't mean you respond to that
Reality by saying I'm never going to
open up my heart but it does mean you
have to exercise some discernment about
who you open up your heart with because
yes there are men who will smell blood
when they hear that kind of stuff and
they will use that against you and I
think some some of this is coming from
the fact that a lot of the people who
feel this way they are thinking of
spaces where they spend a lot of their
lives in where they know they will be
punished for being vulnerable and that
is a reality for men that men have to
deal with yeah last word on this Ryan oh
man
um yeah uh
I love how you framed what you just
framed because
when you hear toxic masculinity it
always implies that the man
is responsible
for the toxic masculinity that is being
projected into the world but the way you
framed it though Millie is
it's not just the man's responsibility
it's also society's responsibility to
not
um yeah to not express those those
traits in a way that is uh manipulating
someone else
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalists private
podcasts available exclusively on
patreon visit patreon.com the
minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and YouTube Channel 100
advertisement free